I also am aware that many of our compatriots voted for me today...
...not to support my ideas...
...but simply to build a barricade against the ideas of the far-right,...
...and at this point, I would like to thank them...
...and tell them that I am aware...
...that this vote gives me a great duty for the next few years.
I am the custodian of their sense of duty,...
...their attachment to our republic and the respect for differences...
...which have been expressed over the past few weeks.
I am also thinking about all of our fellow citizens who abstained.
They remain silent...
...and we also need to respond to that decision.
And lastly, I also would like to mention those who voted for Madame Le Pen,....
...and I know how this is going to be this evening.
No!
Please do not boo anyone.
Since the very beginning, I asked you not to boo anyone.
Because from now on, I'm not a candidate anymore.
I'm now the president of everyone.